oi e aí galera que assiste meu canal
tudo bom com vocês mas olha só quem
diria que estamos nós para mais um vídeo
a ironia do destino eu estou aqui para
falar de arrependimentos a convite da
chevrolet aqui nessa o novo tracker e
não quer que você se arrependa na hora
de comprar um assunto aí tem mais perdeu
derrotar aqui tem wi-fi e sensor de
chuva que dá o like pinga o carro olha
então aproveite eu vejo tá começando e
você ainda tá ajeitando você trazer as
informações que eu vou dizer clique em
gostei tá botar meu primeiro
arrependimento ele tem a ver com comida
e o meu arrependimento nessa história é
que eu fui adulta demais eu vim morar em
são paulo e foi me adaptar esse negócio
de pedir comida que eu nunca tinha
negócio pedir comida eu morava você foi
tomando ao estamos com fome alistao
galeto domingo interior é dia de galeto
leva até para você se situar que dia é
hoje que dia é hoje tem galeto tem é
domingo pegar letrei mas não está quente
está esperando a segunda e galera bem
mas até duro é peça dia hoje não sei viu
galera acabou só tem o retiro do
vinagrete mas não presta mais e aí
chegou em são paulo vou me adaptar o
negócio de comprar pedir comida né me
aventurando sem saber qual era as provas
do lugar pediu uns
e aí eu gosto de moela fui pedir amor
ela chega meu pedido eu pego meu pedido
para o alvo caraca chega aqui na minha
mão mesmo que ele é de plástico você nem
pedir meu deus jesus alguém tem que
avisar tartaruga ela pensa que só tem
canudo eu tento até aqui precisar ok
abrir viu o frango massa legal ver a
moela fui logo na moela quando eu chego
a moela alguma coisa que a criança ela
diz amar mas não deve encomendar morde
não só que eu fui adult mais eu chorei
pensei não gosto tem só um cheirinho
para um cheirinho cheirinho é aí me
arrependi mento até sentir só um
cheirinho esse mês só um cheirinho por
de adultos acordo de pai aí ó o
cheirinho ficou no apartamento meu amigo
foi a madrugada todinha botando para
fora isso aí ainda fui falar com amigo
meu ele tem mano que teve a dor de
barriga pior caminho né pega o meu
caranguejo jaakkola caranguejo aqui
achou que brewpub a casa também tá ruim
na vida essa comida foto pior comida que
eu já comi eu não vou comer uma comida
ruim como ela tava ruim era como ela vai
arrependimento que eu penso
e eu cheguei nos estados unidos agora tá
esse diabo este corona neste mundo
inteiro eu não tenho sintoma nenhum mas
eu fiquei com umas paranoia porque você
fica na paranoia gabaram ela pega a
pessoa e o coronel também o coronel
pegou torrents vale lembrar que eu tô
ricos é o forrest gump ou seja se eu
forrest gump porque é o forrest gamp que
corre pegou o corolla que dirá nós que
não sabe subir uma escada sem gemer a
terra pequena mas tem gente que pega no
manifesto no maninho é meu amigo não
manifesta regina é dinheiro para mim se
tem sentido minha filha ai que não quero
que tenha vírus ainda manifesta eu quero
que não tem as ai ai ai que você tiver o
pai como vai comer verdura não vai ficar
fraco vai pegar o coronavírus vai é
piada não é só vamos a situação caixa
engraçado na hora que ele como muda né
as coisas com o tempo tigamente outras
ameaças aí vai mudando as coisas vão
mudando todo mundo vai se adaptando sabe
a ameaçar também sabe outra coisa que
vai pedir eu me arrependi de brigar na
escola uma vez só
o delegado falando histórico não tenho
histórico sabe não só cagãozinho eu
levei um murro e foi só pelo rio esse é
o momento em que a criança vai começando
a virar adolescente é quando você não
rima mas onde você é muito criança é
tudo é bom dia cara de cala a boca não
lavou hoje é domingo pede cachimbo
cachimbo é de ouro bate no touro touro é
valente bate na gente a gente é fraco
cai no buraco o buraco é fundo dentro do
mundo ele faz sentido hoje é domingo pé
de cachimbo cachimbo é de ouro bate no
touro touro é valente bate na gente a
gente é fraco aí não mas nessa época tá
tudo certo ainda tá rimando só que aí o
menino vai brigar comigo uma vez na
escola e eu não rimei de volta e falou
cala a boca desse mão na boca desse mão
na boca já morreu e disse que ia mandar
minha boca sou eu de quem manda na minha
boca quando eu dar um murro nessa placar
desgraçado vai tomar nesse teu aí meu
amigo pensa que não é burra doada
possível não tava esperando aí não que
eu levei essa é muito médico aquele
momento sabe quando você nunca levou um
murro e você leva você tem aquele inside
assim aí assim que é um murro e aí eu
fiquei naquela atenção naquele
nervosinho de criança sabe e querendo
chorar que a criança quando eu fiquei
com muito ódio no coração
a gente pode coração tá enchendo ela
começa a se transformar ele acredita
muito no desenho quero assistir então
ele tá ali ó
o outro que na segunda eu já dá um susto
aqui que tu faz voo ou que temos aqui
meu deus é o pão mais eu lembrei do goku
apanha mas ele volta ele apanha fica com
esse pela metade mas ele tá sorrindo
acredita em si mesmo borra expulso outra
lapada para empregada nos queixo só que
dessa vez eu já botei o sentimento que
eu fui igual naruto no meu balanço o
naruto pode ser um pouco duro às vezes
embora ele seja jovem seja aprendendo
ele sabe o que significa ser forte como
o pai dele foi
eu vou dar o tá aí depois dessa aí eu
não fui mais não também já tá bom tem
coisa que a gente tem que entender nega
vamos treinar né outro dia a gente volta
e esses foram meus arrependimentos mas é
isso aí chega de arrependimentos porque
eu acho que quem vai ficar repetindo é
você se comprar alguma silver sem
conhecer o novo tracker lá no site da
chevrolet que eu vou tá com a referência
em tecnologia tem wi-fi e motor turbo
mais econômico da categoria ou seja a
frente as da categoria dele ele tá
frente às outras e pode acessar o site
já reservar o seu meu amigo é isso aí
muito obrigado não esquece de clicar em
gostei e se inscrever no canal para não
perder nenhum vídeo pode comentar aqui
embaixo quais são os maiores
arrependimentos da sua vida para eu ler
também eu acho muito engraçado as
histórias de vocês obrigado tamo junto
aí nós um beijo salão e perto e